hi I'm Erik Bosse and Captain Marvel has
arrived providing this final piece of
the puzzle for Avengers end game with
the origin of Nick Fury and the arrival
of Carol Danvers as the latest addition
to the Avengers lineup and as always
Marvel kept those movie leader ushers on
the clock a bit longer with some
traditional post-credit reveals footage
with big implications for the next
Marvel installment so I'm gonna break it
all down and explain its deeper
importance now if you haven't had a
chance to see Captain Marvel yet don't
worry I haven't spoiled anything just go
watch the movie come back here and one
last warning because I will talk about
major plot reveals from the Captain
Marvel movie itself cool okay let's get
started
Captain Marvel features two post-credit
scenes and they both carry some major
importance for the events of Avengers
endgame first a scene that looks like
it'll actually appear in the endgame
film it starts with a close-up of Nick
Fury's pager still emitting that signal
to Captain Marvel just like it was the
moment he dusted away and the
post-credits scene after Avengers
infinity war so in the events of Captain
Marvel Carroll takes away Fury's pager
but she gives it back to him at the end
of the movie with a bunch of new tech
upgrades so that it can transmit across
galaxies and she says only to use it in
case of emergencies before she heads off
into space but back to the scene
suddenly this pager blinks off then we
see Steve Rogers a Natasha Romanov
observing the screen with numbers
reporting the climbing totals of missing
persons around the world I don't think
this happened in real time this is a bit
after the snap I think and these are
just reports of the casualties that are
now finally pouring in and this is the
same screen that we see Bruce Banner
mourning at in the end game trailer
where Scott Lang Peter Parker and Cherie
from Black Panther are among the missing
now this global number climbs up over
3.2 5 billion meaning it's approaching
50% of our actual global population half
would be around 3.8 billion cap says
this is a nightmare and Natasha responds
I've had better nightmares and this
whole moment feels like a callback to
the moment in the beginning of Captain
America Civil War when secretary Ross
guilt-trip them with the statistics of
casualties from past Avengers conflicts
if these numbers are obviously way
higher then Brody walks in saying that
things stopped doing whatever the hell
it was doing and then the three joined
Bruce Banner in the lab where he has
hooked up Fury's pager to a new energy
source to try to keep its signal going
bana reports that whatever the signal
the pager was sending finally crapped
out cap says I thought we bypassed the
battery Rhodey says they did and it's
still
plugged in but it stopped a cap says
reboot it and send the signal again you
know cuz he's an old man and one of
those geeks in the t-shirts at the store
told him that unplugging and re-plugging
stuff is all it takes to fix it then
banner says we don't know what this
thing is Natasha says fury did so just
do it please tell me the second you get
a signal I want to know who's on the
other end of that thing then she turns
around BAM
Captain Marvel Carroll asks concerned
where is fury so yeah the reason this
pager stops signaling is because the
person who's signaling has arrived
Captain Marvel's look has changed her
hair's parted down the middle her suit
now has more gold lining on the
shoulders a star emblem hasn't been
updated wherever she has been and her
time off of Earth has allowed her look
to evolve in looking back on the
Avengers in-game trailer I'm guessing
that it's Captain Marvel that black
widows talking to when she reports what
Dana's did 50% in creatures I guess you
could also be talking to Scott Lang
maybe just talking to both of them
really the big takeaway here is that
there is another major character joining
these for all those theories that we had
in the recent in-game trailer footage a
fifth character might have been
digitally removed to hide a reveal those
might be accurate guys Carol Danvers
might be joining Natasha cap banner and
Rhodey on the Avengers HQ lon and she
might be in that whole lineup March shot
once Scott Lang Thor and rocket join
them and if as I speculated in the past
this is their first step in their
journey through time or through another
reality and the multiverse
Captain Marvel could be the one enabling
that and yes you may have noticed that
cap still does have his beard in this
new footage unlike the trailers we've
seen for in-game which featured him
clean-shaven this could be a sign of the
fact that he's no longer the fugitive
that he was between Civil War and
infinity war and now maybe he's like
cleaned up to try to move on and cheer
people up in this snap der math after
some time has passed or if you really
want to go pull tinfoil
maybe shaving his beard is something cap
has to do for this coming mission like
say going back in time or going into a
parallel timeline and swapping into the
role of his alternate self her previous
self before he had a woodland creature
on his face we're gonna put this in
terms of Rick and Morty it would be hard
for mustache Morty to knock out c-137
Morty and take his place you know you
got to shave the stache and if none of
this makes sense to you don't worry I'm
sure Doctor Strange will explain
everything in holy sin
weeks there's no time to waste let's
move on to the other post credit scene
this one's a shorter one and it just
shows nick fury's empty office but on
his desk hots goose the cat revealed in
this movie to be a fleur kin clerk ins
are alien creatures in the Marvel comics
that look like cats from Earth what do
they actually contain in our mouths with
teeth and tentacles they lay eggs it
inside them are these pocket dimensions
that allow them to swallow large
quantities goose eats a lot of stuff in
this movie including the tesseract and
it is the tesseract that goose costs up
like a hairball in this scene so the
tesseract plays a pretty big role in the
Captain Marvel movie and it looks like
there were some changes to what we knew
at least about the Marvel timeline with
the tesseract like apparently after
Howard Stark came across it on the ocean
floor while searching for cap shield
didn't always have complete possession
of it from that point forward and that
benning's character revealed to be named
Marvel was using a tesseract and of
course the space stone inside of it to
experiment with things like light speed
intergalactic travel the tesseract
stayed inside Earth's orbit and Marvel's
lab but later in the movie Carol puts it
in a lunchbox goose eats it and Nick
Fury ends up holding on to goose for
safekeeping really the tesseract is a
visual symbol of how Captain Marvel's
whole story sets up the origin of Nick
Fury in the Avenger saga we learn in the
final moments of the movie that Fury
decided to rename shields protector
initiative which was he and Coulson's
project to assemble other super-powered
individuals like Carole they renamed it
to the Avengers initiative after
Carole's pilot callsign Avenger nice so
obviously the first post-credits scene
showed a scene from the movie endgame
kind of like how the post-credits scene
after ant-man showed a scene that looks
like it would be in the upcoming Captain
America Civil War
why did you remember the final version
in the Civil War movie played out
slightly different so here's what I'm
wondering do you think this Avengers
post-credits scene will actually be in
endgame or could the Russos still tinker
with the editing to make it all play out
differently in the movie comment down
below with your thoughts follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at leave us
subscribe to this channel a new rock
stars and if you happen to live in the
LA area come check out my live comedy
show darkest timeline it's every first
Friday of the month it Acme in North
Hollywood
features Mesa malarious nerd celebrity
deaths ticket info below thank you for
watching and I gotta say I was a little
bummed that this second post-credit
scene didn't end with
Nick Fury bursting in and saying that's
the you you damned lurking
[Music]